I'm gonna believe this but I'm Shirley
MacLaine
it is so nice to be back home in show
business yeah I've been a lot of places
over the last few years but I've never
seen anything quite like this this looks
like Liberace sauna back I was truly
excited to buy coming here tonight to
see all these sweaty palms and white
knuckles and Richard tuxedos so I folded
myself into this dress I called up my
brother Warren I asked him if he'd bring
me he said he wasn't free but he did
give me a wash and I set my comb out
dude
now I understand it was like a class
reunion backstage for me to sit once
again with the Frank Sinatra and Sammy
Davis jr. in Bob Hope we laughed a lot
and told each other lies about what
we've been doing these past few years
these Sammy said he was sorry
but then we discussed all the good times
we had together - on nights just like
this so let's take a few minutes now and
see some clips from Oscar's home movies
I am here to present the short subjects
award and I'm a short subject
goody
the other day as I was falling off my
bicycle we're delighted to present the
documentary film Awards aren't we Milton
mm-hmm why did you mention Milton now
they know which is which
oh I'm science I they gave me the wrong
envelope way to the n-double a-c-p hears
about this
oh my god the winner is
George C Scott Knudson not coming here
to pick up an Oscar I flew to Greensboro
North Carolina to become chitlin of the
month
this year in addition to the Oscar the
winning actress will also receive three
glorious days at the Sands Hotel in Las
Vegas thank you
look at the hair on that guy will you
I can't tell you how encouraging a thing
like this is
may we have the arms of please the
envelope please the envelope envelope
the army envelope the envelope envelope
envelope yonder the envelope please
here we have the sealed results please
we are most of its armor Gary oh we got
mail
dad you open this you have the longest
nails you open it honey I don't do site
[ __ ]
now you gotta tell me the truth what did
you think oh I can't I like it
get on this show again
I like to make some kind of appreciation
to very important factor which make the
successful lots of my colleagues in this
town I like to think Johan Brahms Johann
Strauss II Chester
we have been asked to announce the
winner of the award for the special
effect do you think we should explain
what special effects are well Peter they
are a little difficult and complicated
to explain maybe we'd better demonstrate
for ideas this is a short love scene
which is shot in the studio without
special effects darling this madness
simply can't go on but I love you
hmm I love you too then let the madness
continue cut taken this is the same
scene shot in the jungle with special
effects darling
it's madness simply can't go on I love
you
I love you too
let's madness continued
that was 1959 he sees before China that
was one of the years I was nominated
myself and I have a message for all of
you nominees out there win or lose just
remember let a smile be your umbrella it
could happen to you there's no business
like show business you've got a rainbow
around your shoulder it'll be a hard
day's nights to count your blessings and
let it be your the top always night and
day so keep your sunny side up from this
moment on happy days are here again
you'll never walk alone like a rolling
stone on the sunny side of the street
all on one LP for only 495
next to present the next award here are
the actor the producer the singer the
director and the choreographer who moved
the American musical from low comedy to
high art to mr. Gene Kelly